let's go next to our caller from the
five seven zero area code who's calling
today from five seven zero that yes it
is
hey dude what's up I call them like a
bunch of times and the first time
getting on there so thank you for
answering love it yeah so I'm a huge
Bernie supporter I donated like 50 times
to him so I'm super depressed about how
you know who turned out in this race
yep and I just I don't know do you think
that what do you think really went wrong
I mean do you really think that we just
didn't attract more people to our kind
of cause and you can do is just too
abrasive kind of how we went about
things with that what you're thinking
listen I've got a couple videos on this
and you can check them out but to sum
this up the long and short of it is
there's a couple different issues number
one
Bernie's policies aren't as popular as
you would think from watching his
rallies and looking at Twitter and
reddit I'm not saying they're unpopular
they just weren't popular enough to
swing the Democratic electorate number
two the Democratic electorate is not as
progressive as it sounds like you are
and as progressive as I am number three
Bernie did have language around his
campaign that didn't help it wasn't a
benefit to keep going with the
Democratic Socialist thing he didn't
gain anything by doing that and it only
possibly lose and so there's a bunch of
different stuff the toxic people around
him there we'll have time for a
post-mortem for sure a deeper
post-mortem okay that's really it uh I
think you taking my call all right
thanks so great great to hear from you I
want to give a quick shout out to one of
our sponsors VIN Chara watches they're
giving my audience 15% off your entire
order when you go to david pakman.com
slash watch maybe you don't usually wear
a watch and you've been thinking about
looking for one to elevate your look or
you've been thinking about replacing the
one you have check out vin chair oh it's
an american company all of their watches
are built in small batches from high-end
materials they look amazing and they
look like something you'd spend a lot of
money on but ever even chair Oh watch
ranges from a hundred and fifty to three
hundred dollars I went on their website
and picked out the
in white and silver really love the look
the combination of the white face and
the beige band really love this one they
also sent me the Kairos limited release
gold reserve set totally different style
this one would make a fantastic gift for
a couple people I can think of in my
family any time you see me wearing a
watch on the show I'm wearing a van
share o watch go through their
collection I know you'll find something
you like and you'll get 15% off when you
go to david pakman.com slash watch